leave the keys you still do that thing
leave the
keys we can offer our biggest discounts
on 30% recyc and Ultra Premium laser
okay okay can I use your phone yeah sure
go ahead let me talk to you about a few
of the other things we can offer namely
we know the tax season's coming up so by
April 1st we can have you fully stocked
discount prices on ink cartridges three
and also any forms that you're going to
need seven you can custom make
them I appreciate what you guys are
saying but it uh makes more fiscal sense
to go with one of the big guys sure
that's true we can't compete with their
prices but let me ask you something how
important to you is customer service
it's very please keep holding your call
is very important to us M it's one of
the big guys been on hold this whole
time and this is D
Mifflin mlin customer Serv it's Kelly
hey Kelly it's Jim oh my God Jim how are
you I to tell you here's my card it's
got my cell number my patro number my
home number and my other peder number I
never take vacations I never get sick
and I don't celebrate any major holidays
all right all right I get it we got a
deal all right the salesman have a
commission cap but we figured out a way
around it Lloyd gross is a fictional
salesman we invented to how do I put
this steal from the company em bezzel to
commit fraud okay it sounds sketchy but
it helps us get more money yes Pam made
a drawing of Lloyd he is a blend of all
the
salesmen you sir no thank you I never
let anyone walk behind me seven out of
10 attacks are from the rear okay well
that still leaves a 30% chance that I'll
Attack you from the front uh yeah but
it'll be easier to stop I can always
block the blow or I can counter it with
it Stone and Sun Suit Warehouse recently
lost their paper provider they're a
family-owned
business Jim and I used to clean up at
those we'd go in pretending to be family
Brothers we did it at a family-owned Law
Firm at a family-owned construction
company and a family-owned motorcycle
store Jim and Dwight shupert I was the
dynamic likable winner that was doed
upon by
Mom and Jim was the closeted foot
fetishist pretending to belong the
client never knew any of that but I knew
I hope you've been paying your wig
storage bills Jimbo because it's time
for another episode of handsome and
stinky paper Brothers for hire sorry
stinky you can't do it too busy oh God
this again you're stinky seriously
you're going to set me back uh yeah
that's the safest part of a car in the
event of a crash driver always protects
his side
first Jim
you know it would be really dastardly If
We snuck out of here and got to The
Client
First he's
running damn
it damn
it what what is this supposed to be it's
a monkey Jim get real this is not a
monkey it's got got a hoola skirt and a
blue nose hold on hold on is this him
what is that
him it's him do something get out what
what am I going to do I don't go slash
his tires go dead his
hood that's it oh that's great that's
like a 5c delay Dwight go does this
thing have turbo nitrous hit the NS NS
you mean like in Fast and Furious oh
yeah I definitely have NS hit the ns are
you sure yes brace yourself three two
one here we
go ready go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go
go all right right
[Music]
yeah Dwight what are you
doing go go take the stairs now talking
about I don't even know where the stairs
are I'll stall him
go
what are you
doing I'm going to activate the seismic
fail safe we'll be stuck between floors
for
hours my pants fell down what my pants
fell down I don't have a
belt hello sir good day Dwight K Sho
under myin Scranton forgive my pants
they fell down an appointment with Mr
ramish please right now is fine no no no
I was here first dght k shw
what's going on Mr ramish Harry janone
Dunder Mifflin Syracuse I was here first
Sor this made an appointment me stop you
all right here I've already picked a new
paper supplier wait it's not DM UA is it
no no it's not Dunder Mifflin at all
actually it's big red Paper Company big
red Paper Company
mhm yes yes yes here's what's going to
happen I am going to have to fix you
manage you to on a more personal
scale a a more micro form of management
Jim what is that called micro boom yes
now Jim is going to be the client Dwight
you're going to have to sell to him
without being aggressive hostile or
difficult let's go all right
[Music]
fine hello hello this is Dwight fruit
from the dundermifflin Paper Company W
that's great cuz I need paper excellent
then you are in luck because we are
having a limited time offer only on
everything wow this is my lucky day ask
him his name what is your name sir I am
Bill
butlicker really that's your real name
how dare you my family built this
country by the way be respectful Dwight
please oh yes Michael could you hold on
one second that's my other line what no
but I hello yeah no I'm just on the
phone with this stupid salesman he's so
dumb probably just going to keep him on
the line forever and not buy
anything okay it's up to you to change
his mind sorry that was a family
emergency oh no what's wrong you know
what that's private boundaries twight
come on I'm sorry Mr Butler as I was
saying we're having a limited a little
bit louder I'm hard of hearing he's hard
if he's an old man okay as I was saying
right now we are having talk louder okay
our prices have never been lower you
have to talk louder never been lower
louder son buter our prices have never
been lowered stop it stop it
he that is totally in a appropriate you
never yell at the client you never
listen to me sir here we go the three
words I would describe you as is
aggressive hostile and definitely
difficult Please Mr am I rate right now
please give me another chance Mr but
licker give me the phone I have to put
you on with my boss well I should hope
so who is this hello this is Michael
Scott regional manager well this is
William M butlicker hello Mr butlicker
how may we help you Michael I like the
sound of your voice you know what I'm
going to do I'm going to buy 1 million
worth of paper products
today see how it's done thank you very
much sir I don't think you'll regret it
you know I did you are the master there
is one condition Michael yes you have to
fire the salesman that treated me so
terribly don't do it
Michael it's a million dollar
sale give me a cup of coffee me too or
do you also have a monopoly on thirst
all right guys it didn't work out for
any of us so we're still on the same
team let me get these no let him get his
own he's got Syracuse money you know
your partner's got a lot of attitude but
I like that how long you guys been
dating Jim couldn't land me in a
thousand years you're saying there's a
jam shut
up